to call terror group is it possible to
have a rational I've asked you two
questions should aass stay in power and
are they a terror group you're refusing
to answer either of them that is very
telling talk TV is the only place where
you get the truth you've done a book on
poetry poetry and music for the many I
love purgy we can agree on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
TV tonight on PE morg on sented I've
come to Santa Anita racetrack in Los
Angeles one of the great sporting arenas
in America I've come here because
Frankie Dori one of the great jockeys in
history and certainly the most
charismatic announced his retirement
last year in England and went on a
farewell tour that was so successful
he's ended up un retiring a school for
you guys I deciding to prolong my career
I'm going to go to the United States
from next year and uh keep on following
me he want of the new challenge and he's
come here to America to pursue it right
here on this track and he's already
having great success Frankie Goes to
Hollywood and I'm going to be very
uncensored that is definitely
[Music]
true
so Frankie last time I spoke to you you
had retired yes that was it you were
never getting back on a horse
competitive again and yet here I find
you in Hollywood Frankie's gone to
Hollywood goes to why did you change
your mind so basically I um when I
started this year no sorry last year uh
I thought well I'm going to be 53 on a
stop at a top obviously we talked about
this before you know watching the World
Cups see Ronaldo on the bench and I
thought well I want to stop and then
people remember that I was good I don't
want to stop that you know I can't get a
ride and then I I said well I give
myself a year I want to say goodbye to
everyone all the countries that I've
been including my own Italian country
and then when I started um I started
winning and then I thought well this is
not going to carry on and then I kept on
winning I kept on win I got to about
August and just couldn't stop winning
and I I started having regrets thinking
you know am I ready to stop you know I'm
still u in demand but because I made
such a big deal that I was going to stop
and everybody else made a such a big
deal the greatest Fair world toour since
SRA he kept coming back yeah including
including a lifestyle statue unveiled by
Queen C
Alaska but then uh you know I have to
leave with myself and I thought well I'm
not ready to start stop because I'm
still doing so well but I kind of run
out of avenues because it would have
been foolish to to say would have carry
it on in in England after what I said so
I only had one option to come here in
California where I like very much and uh
it'll just give me a little bit extra
time to get out of my system it's a it's
a stunning RAC trck I mean I've had a
home in La for a long time I've never
been here you come here in the morning
it's early only you would get me out of
bed this early and you come and you the
sun was coming up and the Magical scene
of the Santa and eer track it's really
it's a magical place it's amazing I'll
be honest with you is probably the one
of the best looking tracks in the world
with the mountains in the backdrop uh
the track itself is set in a beautiful
piece of land you got this massive palm
trees in the middle of it uh yeah I mean
the the the the light I uh I mean if if
that doesn't take your breath away no
other tracks will and uh every morning
when I come here I feel like I'm blessed
to be able to you know enjoy my last bit
to my career in such a beautiful place
interestingly the very start of your
career you did come here and you did a
couple of years maybe was I did four
Winters here I came here when I was 16
as a illegal worker I came here on a on
a tourist visa and uh I mean the first
couple of weeks I go into the track
without getting caught and then
eventually I uh I got caught by security
so I had to use other entrances to get
in when I've spoken to you we've known
each other a long time uh about the the
hard reality of being a jockey yeah the
amount of injuries you sustain and this
is not even jump stuff this is just flat
racing talk me through the injuries
you've had over the years well first of
all um you know we go extra fast you
know we go over 40 m hour and you know
we we we actually about 6 foot off the
ground so and we raise inches to each
other so do you have any padding at all
or not we have little little padding but
that's not because obviously weight is a
big issue so you can't you can't put a
AR like a hammer around you because he
weighs and uh so one little mistake can
uh end up in in an accident and and when
you when you go that fast and that speed
you
break uh you know we talking about I
mean I'm I feel like one of the Blessed
ones I did you know you I broke my uncle
twice both of my elbows I broke my
collarbone I broke my
shoulder uh ribs fingers and I feel like
you know I'm actually I did all right
it's really yeah there's a lot of people
in my sport that that that that broke a
lot more uh I mean when you start this
job
the the smell the speed the adrenaline
the crowd the excitement gets you sucked
into this sport you never feel or think
about the danger you know I mean if you
knew when you were going to fall you
wouldn't do it because it is dangerous
but but what I said to you just now the
the the the highs overpower the laws of
getting injured and and and messing
yourself up you know like I said when
you what was the toughest injury you had
uh tough injuries I mean they're all
tough you know because what was the
hardest to get back from well uh
shoulder well I brought my uncle that
took took a long time because obviously
you need your uncle to to do balance in
the stups shoulder again that that that
fixed quickly but then the pain is was
there for a year uh you know every
injuri is is is bad because like every
Sportsman will tell you we always try to
come back earlier than he should have
done because we do want to miss out you
know because the longer you stay off
then you know you you in danger of
missing off on a on a good how much
you've had 3,000 yeah winners you've had
three decades of of racing about that
yeah it's incredible stats 30 30 this is
my 37th year can you imagine how much of
that percentage wise have you spent in
some form of
pain uh you get used to it I I can't
really don't know much percentage if you
were
guessing I would say a quarter of it
really yeah a quarter of my career you
know then always had some sort something
yes but you you don't think like that
because you know the it's always a g
dangling Cara is always a big race
coming up is always that chance that you
will win a big race somewhere and that
kind of is the best best painkiller in
the world the other really tough
physical demand of of racing is your
weight yes what is your fighting way
what's your best way would you say I uh
in America here I ride um at uh 118
pounds what is equivalent of the Aon six
in in English Pounds about half a Morgan
yes uh I would say my body weight be a
stor than that i' probably be about 9 10
if I eat on Norm more life but uh so
what do you have to do to hit that that
RAC I uh basically I I train myself not
to eat bad things for the last 30 years
average day what what would you bread I
don't need junk food uh I have a little
snack in the morning and just try to
have one meal in the evening uh mainly
uh
protein uh salads fish chicken you know
I don't eat meat very often but it
depends on people uh but you know I you
know I won't be lying to you I sometimes
I have a piece of chocolate or you know
probably have one bowl of pasta every
three
months uh you know I train every day to
keep my weight down uh you know it is
it's a lifestyle you know it's a it's a
it's a lifestyle it's a big sacrifice
it's a big sacrifice and uh 37 years
yeah and I I you know it sounds funny
but I even when I do have time off uh I
always go and reach for a chicken Cesar
salad you never see me eat a burger or
because I think my body now can't take
it anymore can you drink alcohol or not
I like wine because I'm Italian yes but
in moderation but like I said my body is
now used to not having those kind of uh
rich food that uh yeah I I I'll be
honest with you I now then I'm finishing
my career I'm finding it easier maybe
because you know uh I have a routine I
don't go out as much uh that's why
California suits me I mean everything
shuts up here it does yeah but uh you
know I guess 10 years ago and I wanted
to go out every night did not suited me
but you've talked before about being Bic
at very stages I did 10 years of in Bic
yes uh guess in my between my 30s and
40s and you would throw up before racism
yeah th I would have a meid at night and
throw up or sometimes I would have a big
breakfast and throw up but I didn't do
it because I wanted to do it I did it
because you know the skill doesn't lie
it was a a way of lifestyle that I chose
to to have you know no different to I
guess mothers have the same problems or
teenage kids they want I think you said
you do you had to
use diuretic everything I tried
everything I tried U uh diuretic pills
laxatives uh made myself sick I remember
driving car with a sweatsuit with the
heaters on you know I you know you try
you try extremer things in in your job
because you have to do the weight I
don't think anybody what has done what
I've done and people people still do it
they actually choose that because they
like it it's because they have to do the
weight simple as that I mean it's it's a
pH physically very hard sport yes I
don't think most people realize until
they Listen to Someone Like You talk
about it just how physically demanding
it is first of all like we we explain is
is the diet then you have to have you
have to be ultra fit because in a space
of a day you can ride six or eight races
right and you know you you handling
1,000 pound worth of absolute explosive
flesh I mean these horses are powerful
and you have to control them and uh so
that's a physical demand the diet and
then also the injuries you know what I
mean when you do have the injuries uh
you have to cope with that so overall I
mean I didn't sell it very well right if
you want to become a jocky well I think
it's the reality of it right that is the
reality but you know we we do it because
you know we addicted to it with that
feeling I mean I watched the tape last
night preparing for this interview when
you went through the card at waras won
all seven races only time anyone's ever
done that and the last race you're on a
horse where you don't think you got a
chance of winning what's the name of the
horse FJ right and you're you're you're
leading but Pat edre is coming behind
you you can hear his whip I could he and
you think he's going to be he's going to
be and somehow you get a second win with
this horse and it and it wins that
moment when you cross the line and knew
you'd gone through the card at Alaska
what is that like what's that feeling
like well you get that feeling
of basically it's like um everything
when you cross that line everything just
goes in slow motions you just you know
you you know you're just Galloping on
top of these Source you got time to look
at a crowd and everybody's going
ballistic they only last for a few
seconds and you back to real
life and it's you know is in a way is
very selfish is is an emotion that
nobody can you can ever explain I mean
like I said never mind the dangers but
the you know the crowd the smell the
speed the excitement and and and you
cross that line and the Euphoria what
hits you is incredible that's and that's
why you get addicted and that's why I do
it because and is that why you can't
really give it up yet yes you know
obviously it'd be much easier if I if I
didn't get a chance of winning that many
or you need the money right I mean you
you've made enough money not to worry
about yeah but you do it because you
love it because otherwise it's hard to
let go you know I I I go great
sympathies for other Sportsmen that that
that to stop I mean I stopped for a week
and I didn't like it so you know um you
know I'm I'm I know 53 sounds a big
number but I still feel that I'm still
competitive even though that I'm racing
with jockies 30 years younger than well
how many of them actually weren't even
alive when you started I would say 70%
really was crazy right that's that's
nuts it's crazy and how do they treat
you uh the it's funny because now you we
call it the the jocks room right I love
this jockey room this is this is amazing
history this place is timeless you can
come here at 16 or 53 we all the same
age it's only when you step out of there
that you feel your age but when you come
here it's great bant we all treat each
other the same and uh if you do
something wrong everybody jumps on you
what about this because I always think
in any sport what differentiates the
good from the great is is a mental thing
absolutely absolutely and that comes
with
experience um nobody is born with that
great
mindset uh experiences of Life uh second
stances
emotions uh you know when when you're
young you have emotions but you don't
know how to deal with them right uh so
as you get older you deal with emotions
with um when you know when you get B
when you're nervous you know I'm I'm no
different to anyone even in my age I
still get a dry mouth you know uh if I
write a favor a big race I'm the first
one to tell you of course I'm nervous
but nervous is good because now I know
how to deal with it but you can't teach
that that you you got to learn it you've
also got to have in your sport in
particular a ferocious work ethic right
you have to yeah you can't wing it can
you no you can't uh physically you got
to be ultra fit you got to put your own
work and then but also you got to have
that Natural Touch you know you can work
as much you you can but you got
sometimes you go let things happen you
got to use your Natural Instincts you
cannot predict how the race is going to
go or no stri can predict how he's going
to score but you got to use your natural
ability and that's a difference from you
know being a normal joy to be a
superstar you know and this applies the
same to any other sport you know when
you see Geniuses like me
uh you know they they do things that I
don't think they who do you most admire
in other sports oh I admire all sports
you know obviously I'm a big football
supporter uh I even admire the boxers
the the the wor FY they have to put up
uh the rby players you know I don't know
too much about Cricket but you know
sometimes you see uh like like the World
Cup this year was you know I know India
got beat but was amazing game you know I
like all these great sport sporting
events and as you know the super B
coming up that's be another amazing
event we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we're on your smart speaker as
well criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn do you know what I
love about to today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC Mouse
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruise
fil sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party
hi kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes I cannot continue my
work when I say I am God I'm not joking
did you feel Elvis was controlling I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions are you prepared to call
her a terror group is it possible to
have a rational I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on that
[Music]
you've had two moments in your life
since you became a professional jobke
which could have ended everything one
your own fault and I'll come to that in
a moment this the first one though was
the plane crash which is really one of
those moments in your life where it was
a light aircraft you were going from one
race course to another the pilot very
sadly died you were with your great
friend and manager Ray Cochran at the
time you both managed to get out um just
before it all went up in in Flames what
do you remember about what happened that
day what I remember about um in a
nutshell you know I can explain it um
it'll take hours but basically on take
off something went
wrong Lane went down and what were you
feeling as it went down what I feeling
when I was down I I looked at Ray and as
I was staring as the ground was
approaching I didn't have have time to
scream and I was just disappointed that
I was going to die I I was thinking to
myself I'm 29 years old I just had a six
month child why are you taking me now I
was just disappointed why now you know I
mean I I got so much through forward in
life that's all I felt you really
thought you were about to die that's it
no two question about it and some
miracle what was the landing like when
some miracle well the the wing of the
plane clipped this Bank where made the
plane
rotate anyway never mind that so it was
just like an enormous bit in the washing
machine don't of what
happened can you remember that yeah I
remember the impact and then uh I
obviously my skin on my forehead went
all the way back so my blood was pouring
in front of my face and I was in a state
of concussion I guess where I had 18 18
Vision I could see the two planes two
engines on fire and I saw the pilot inch
down in
front but I couldn't move I was just
paralyzed I just couldn't I knew that to
get out but could not move and then Ray
gave me a nudge was next to me and he he
kind of woke me up and I realized that I
broke my leg and when I went to get out
you know was a six-seater twin engine
the the plane was like in bits the the
door didn't exist anymore luckily for us
the luggage door was just in the back of
the seat was half open and as I crawled
out I realized that the broken leg Ray
pushed me out then he crawled out and he
dragged me away from here to the end of
the room and then and he was concerned
that the so much fuel was on the plan
that he could all go up and then he
tried he took his jacket off and he
tried to go back for the pile and the
plane exploded and he was burned from
head to toe uh and he was you know I
couldn't I could hear him yelling of
anger because he couldn't get the
pilot so you
know it was a trauma for me uh I lost my
good friend my pilot I was lucky twice
lucky to be alive the crash and lucky to
be alive then Ray got me out of that
plane I couldn't be burned alive you
know it took me 17 years to get back on
the plane uh did you really yeah I mean
I was Scar and even now again how how
long between you getting out of the
wreckage and it going up was it seconds
really seconds so you were seconds from
just yeah from I mean imagine the the
two Wings playing full of fuel second so
Ray saved your life he did yeah yeah and
saved my life and I owe my life and I
when he when he had big neck problems
after the crash so I told him to quit
racing and he became my manager for 20
years so do you ever a talk about it
together I R never talked about it we
talked about it 20 years after really
yeah we had a toast together uh raay a
very deep man he you know yeah never
took the about it and I'm I'm now going
personal always talked about he never he
kept it to himself and yeah I mean
it's you can't explain what we've been
through uh and there is ways to deal
with it perhaps I should have SE help
but and I had good family around me and
you know well I am I shouldn't have be
there we go it's an extraordinary story
imagine imagine yeah twice and I read
that um that later you were thinking you
were 29 you were thinking you'd always
wanted as an ambition young Italian to
buy a Ferrari right and you just thought
well what am I waiting for I could have
died just you went B Ferrari I said to
myself when I get to 30 if I got enough
money I love to get a Ferrari being in
Italian and at 29 and a half after I got
out of the hospital as soon as I could
walk a little bit I went to get myself
one I thought you know why and you know
it did change my life in you know I
would say I was if I that didn't happen
I probably would have been more
successful in my career but you know I
become why because you spend more time
with family yeah I was more focused and
I didn't I was tonal Vision but after
that you know
family you know I've got five children
yeah uh you know I juggle life and rid
in and try to get the B of both world
and you know a lot of times you think
you know why should you get upset you
Afters what happened to me a lot of
things really don't really matter you
know the other thing that could have
ended everything for you professionally
was when you tested positive for cocaine
in 2012 and you really struggled for
quite a long time 18 months to get
another good ride you thought maybe
that's it that was a self-inflicted
wound what when you look back at that I
mean obviously fortunately you had a a
sort of Savior who came along and picked
you up and said right I'm going to I'm
going to back you so basically yeah oh
look I was a silly boy you know went out
took some drugs got tested a week later
and it wasn't my system you know I
wasn't doing it because I was rri it was
more Rec recreational and yeah quite rly
so I admitted it I got six months band
took my family out of school we went
around the world because you obviously
they were getting bullied they were
getting picked out of school you know
you know Paparazzi outside my house how
did that make you feel that you brought
that on everyone not great uh I think
the biggest disappointment is telling my
own
parents how did they react not great my
my dad being old fashioned um kids you
know that thought it was quite funny
having Paparazzi outside there to
smuggle me in and out of the car with a
blanket uh we had a good time together
around the world and um you know I
served my time I did my six months I
came back and I thought well
everything's going to be on on kidori
come back but you know obviously nobody
would touch me you know you know for
some reason you said you felt like a
leper it was like yeah I mean I took it
you know it took me I just couldn't get
right for for about a year and then um
yeah I got to a point a year later I
couldn't
see the light at the end of the tunnel I
thought well I've got no other choice
you know I can't I can't get any
business so maybe I have to look to do
something else maybe in what would you
have done if you hadn't been just
probably maybe going to the
media uh but you know I wasn't ready to
quit you know you know how are you
feeling in that Wilderness period I felt
terrible I felt Terri terrible and you
know and then the worst thing was you
know even my wife started doubting me
you know she said to me the famous word
show me how good you are really you know
we one day you know we were struggling
to pay bills and things were going bad
and we all end up in an argument and um
and she R you know all your life you're
telling me how good you are look at us
now we can't pay bills just show me how
good you are and that wow that that's a
moment and that was like you know
somebody shot me in the heart right you
know coming from my own wife and that
really got me fired right up and I just
said nothing and I put my head down and
I persisted and carried on carried on
and 180 months later a year later I goes
and win the Epson D on Golden Horn and
with a massive party at home few drinks
with friends that feeling when he
crossed the line and he won the do oh
that was the feeling but but the feeling
was when I got home and we did the party
you say to your wife that's how good I
am so basically when everybody left the
house and we were sitting there and I
said do you remember what you said to me
yo I said that's it I said don't ask me
again I've done it now so that was it so
you know what did she say I she said
that at the time I needed something like
that to to probably did to make me
believe or to give me a push and yeah I
mean those famous words show me how good
you are that they they imprinted in my
house trust me that's an amazing story
mad but you know I
think you know sometimes we'll need
someone to to to touch that nerve yes
you know and fire you up again and
that's at the time that's what I needed
and you know oh better person than your
own wife who knows me so well to to just
you know and she said you know I just
needed to say that and and it worked how
important has she been Catherine to you
well you know she's been with me 30
years I mean I feel sorry for her then I
brought her through this crazy life you
know never mind self-inflicting stupid
things that I've done playing Crashers
near kill myself every day worry that I
could end up in hospital when I ride you
know it must be a worry for for a woman
to marry somebody like me but she St
with me we had some amazing times
together and you know she's been so good
to me do you remember when you proposed
to her I did yeah I was in scalini one
of my favorite Italian restaurant in
London and uh yeah it was a nice
afternoon in London and I got a man and
I remember everybody in the restaurant
in the restaurant everybody stood up and
clapped yeah really it was it was sweet
did you have a ring I did have the ring
yes yeah of course and I also I was told
because I'm not English I was told I to
go and see the father I went to see
Cathy's dad the night before and I got a
full lecture from his father and how did
you sell yourself to him well I said
listen I came to ask the hand of your
daughter and he sat me down I said
listen he said before you start this
she's going to finish her studies you
going to look after her give me a proper
wash down proper goody English wash down
but yeah great yeah yeah I'm you know
five kids what's the secret to a lasting
marriage do you think
uh I think we don't leave in each
other's
pocket um she lets me get on with what I
have to do she's been Ultra busy with
children um and we meet in the middle
you know we have our own things that we
like and you know she just gives me free
range to be what I have to be you know
uh you know I'm sure man of the races
that's what I am and she just lets me do
you know what I have to do but it's very
important that to have that backing
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about to today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes R unexpected item in
bagging a know are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from at Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan about Twitter you
sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV the other family that you've been
very attached to is the royal family
yeah who love you you love them um
particularly you had an amazing
relationship with her majesty the Queen
the late great Queen when did you first
meet her do you remember I course I did
probably thir I know I knew over 30
years back in the days when I was in my
early 20s I used to write for a trainer
Ian baling and Ian baling had most of
the Queen's horses and uh so that's how
that's how matter and uh you know even
30 years that I met her every time I met
her nervous wreck she had this [__] but
she always had the ability to make you
feel to make you feel uh
good uh so I tell you a funny story I
went I want a big
race 15 years ago and it was a Sunday so
after racing I I had the big party it
was a lovely spring day and I left all
the doors open I had dogs and 200 people
turned up we had an amazing party and I
woke up the next day and um house was
destroyed full of bottles and and I
realized I lost one of my dogs but she
had a tag
and it was a message on the answer
machine and the message said I we found
your dog please call us back on this
number and the lady who found the dog
was uh Caroline
Warren the queen racing manager wife so
I ran Caroline said I Caroline sorry but
I heard that you have my dog can I come
and collect it and she said listen if
you come this
evening uh the Queen's coming to New
Market to see the horses in the morning
so you can say hi to the queen and pick
up the
dog I mean great idea so my wife's in
the in the courtyard she's cleaning the
ponies and I opened the window said
honey I found the dog and she said where
is the dog oh the Queen's got it she
said don't be silly no no I'm swear the
Queen's got it going to pick it up
tonight so my daughter got all dressed
up we went to get the dog and um and
there she was she was was having a j
tonic next to the fire and I had a J in
tonic with her and she spent 20 minutes
talk talking to my daughter about ponies
and about school and then they let the
dog out the dog ran towards me and PE in
the Persian
carpet in front of the queen in front of
the queen of John Warren and uh Queen
started laughing and John got really red
face got really upset and that moment I
got sced out said uh we got to have
dinner now you better go
fank but the queen was just creased
laughing she was so funny to be around
she also had an amazing knowledge of
horse racing this wasn't someone who did
it as like a little mild hobby she she
knew everything right yes six years
listen it's incredible she wrote till
she was in the 90s around wind Windsor
Park and yeah of course she bred horses
for six years you rode 50 winners for it
yeah IE over 50 winners yeah amazing did
they always feel a little bit extra
special when you won a race for the
queen but look when you when you got the
colors in the peg like that there was
already excitement you know and you know
amazing Royal you know I mean she she
was racing the a family started racing
300 years ago King Charles the first 350
years ago so racing is in the blood and
she had so much knowledge and she loved
that she absolutely loved racing didn't
you used to occasionally triy cck the
accent with it we you know she used to I
tried but didn't go very well but what
was it you said to her how
are but I said what did she say she said
to me I'm still
here I'm usually just bow say your
majesty but I kind of froze and I went
how are you and she went I'm still here
but she was she
was what would you talk about just
generally when you saw her everything
she liked to hear the gossip about
the inside gossip oh you know you know
which trainer was going out with all
yeah all the the juicy gossip really yes
yeah yeah she very interested about that
and you know she she just loved to be
around racing
people when she died it was a huge
moment for the country you're you're a
kind of angelized Italian you're Italian
but you've obviously spent a lot of time
in England what what was that moment
like for you how did you hear that she
died well I saw her the last time I saw
her was a Royal Ascot and she obviously
quite free she couldn't get up up and
down the stairs and they made the little
room next to the paddock so she could
watch the racing and to a point IIA took
the horse inside the little booth to to
show the horse and yeah and you know for
you know you always feel she's
Immortal and when it hases happen is a
shock you know because I felt she was
Immortal and I remember we were meant to
race at Don Casta that night and race
got cancel quite rightly so yeah and it
just how did you
hear I think we just heard on the radio
I think from
Funko and uh yeah just I felt quite
emotional when I yeah it was just come a
shock real shock like I said because you
know I always felt that she was Immortal
and you know we Mo we lost a great
person great mon Monarch well a great
person and you know I'm the first one to
say that I met her for 30 years you know
she really touched me the way she made
you feel and the way she was and you
know I'm not the only one I mean I would
say millions of people feel the same but
actually very few would have had the
access you did yeah all that kind of
relationship because she loved horse
riding racing almost as much as anything
else in her life yeah you know probably
saw other side of it I mean a lot of
times a s in in
events and she would make a detour to
find somebody into race him because she
kind of find that exciting uh yeah I'm
I'm I'm very lucky and and also the new
king you know I I was you know I I never
really met Kings Charles like a year you
know he came Royal ASCO five days
straight to a point on day five I
actually I was invited to have lunch at
wind Castle on day five and I did the
the the the ride on the
carriage and he turned around to me and
said um you know my my my mom would have
been proud to see me racing five days
straight so I think we got him
interested in austr and and it's good
because it's nice to keep the tradition
and especially now that we are in this
Joy room I feel very proud that is
beginning to enjoy enjoy racing you
recently went to the Jungle in Australia
competed in I'm a celebrity you were the
first to be kicked out of there which I
think is probably a blessing I don't
know why you went me too me too it's
like at least you haven't got to stay in
there with these was it even remotely an
enjoyable experience or is it just as
awful as I imagin it is well it was
exactly what I thought you know you got
to have a a mindset
and if you got a [__] in your arm or
any weaknesses it's going to find you
you know um is H where we are you sleep
in a
bench uh you eat rice and
beans the dongy or the toilet how used
to call it is all on the ground more L
um the humidity and the loneliness you
know because you there by yourself okay
you with other people you go no watch no
contact from the the outside world how
did you feel about being the first to to
lead I don't really know what was
televised on TV because I was there 24
hours and they cut it down into one hour
and talking to the people outside the
you broad interested the politics Nigel
farage or people arguing you know I'm
not I'm not a fighter I'm a lover I I
had a great time in there but they never
a sh all the fun times than I had you
know they were more interested about
what farage or Britney Spear sister were
going to say course they they didn't
care what a jockey were going to say so
but you know it was an experience and
I've done it I take that box and that's
it you also were named in the top six
nominees for the sports person of the
year on the BBC very prestigious and
you've won it uh many years ago uh to be
in the top six when you're 53 years old
of the top six Sports people in Britain
pretty incredible I think the only one
um born when I started riding was too
abroad all the others wer even born it's
quite scary yeah amazing obviously this
late in my career and and also racing is
not a football Cricket tennis rugby
sport followed or or like the Olympic so
it's great privilege for me to be
nominated and also for my sport you know
because I promote myself I also like to
promote my sport how did you feel about
a member of the women wom's lioness's
team winning given they actually hadn't
had a very good year yeah they lost the
World Cup they didn't qualify for the
Olympics and they still won it having
won it the year before maybe I should
lose a bit more to get to get in the top
three should it only go to people who've
actually won something that year I I I I
I I saw your podcast you did I know I I
I I agree with you but you know even St
abroad I mean amazing it's last year
he's won everything and and he didn't
win it either but is what
people uh watch or like so but are we
becoming Frankie a country which has
moved from celebrating great Champions
and winners to now we we almost
celebrate losing that's what it feels to
me we've moved as a society from a
really the underdog yeah but I don't
it's not even the underdog this okay
you've lost we're going to give you a
participation prize right well perhaps
perhaps so you know I'm must say all the
six nominees including myself I mean you
know we all had done something great but
uh you know it's it's down to the public
to decide and um and I'm I'm not bitter
like I said already been nominated I
feel like a
winner we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals do use XL Bully dogss As
Weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn do you know what I
love about to today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear and off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it's hard to know whether
it's a f or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by as to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pound so far so 140 million
pounds so far result nil absolutely nil
are we only going to be trusting source
like meta and Google where is our
unbiased news going to come from Kell in
winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he into a branch of
McDonald MC mous man MC mous man MC he
should be easy enough to catch this guy
shouldn't he I mean he's got a house
full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place that where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
[Music]
that what's been the greatest Accolade
for you you've won so many things what's
the one that meant the most to you well
I'll be honest with you uh my biggest
achievement obviously winning seven
races in a day but overall you know
being on top of my game for 30 years
thought you know it's hard enough to do
it for 10 so to do it for 30 I can see
and be proud of it that uh you know I'm
still comp erative at 53 so how long do
you think you can realistically continue
for how long is a piece of string as
long as it's going to be like sonara
just keep retiring and coming back well
no listen I'm not going to I feel like
uh this is this is my last bit of my
career here in California I enjoy it you
know if you can get one or two more
years out of it it' be great but in my
sport you never know uh you know uh
fingers crossed then I don't have any
accident and I still compartive enough
and uh if and get like I said another
one or two years be great pie of P do
you like America love it what what do
you like about it uh I feel a bit Freer
than I am in England I don't sound
spoiled but okay I'm famous on the racet
trck but I can step out paint my toils a
wear a minis skirt nobody cares are you
doing that no I don't do that I'm just
telling you that's the difference right
in in England you on Europe you get
judged what you wear or what you do you
always looking yourself behind that's
the difference than I find a bit more uh
relaxing you have a very competitive dad
he was a champion jockey many times
himself gave you a hard time when you
were young still is still gives you a
hard time to it still is it still tells
me what should I should have done you
know which Gap I should have took
obviously my dad was a jockey
professional jockey very successful very
successful so I I can't pull a wall over
his eyes because you know exactly when I
did right or wrong you were quite from
what I've read you were quite a sort of
shy retire young kid right you weren't
this charismatic Thunderball and your
first race your dad gave you a pony you
had a first race you came last and you
fell off after the finishing one that's
right when that happened did you ever
imagine in your wildest thoughts that
you might end up as one of the great
jockies in history no absolutely not I
was U quiet
nice uh non- amiti person then my dad
kicked me out of home it didn't kicked
me out he sent me to England but it was
like being kicked out because like I
couldn't speak English going to a
different country I was getting bullied
the the weather the food everything else
was different and uh
but that that man me up and also I
didn't want to embarrass my dad so it
made me work extra hard and then the
writing started I realized that oh maybe
I'm quite good and that is snowed out of
my control I started winning and then
from a little ball it became a big ball
and then I became what I am now but I
never started with the ambition that I
was going to be great when you ride now
you there a little part of you still
trying to prove a point to your dad oh
yes oh yeah yeah my daddy's I don't
think my daddy's ever said well done
really yeah no no he's never never I
don't think he has even when you won the
seven races it might just as a grunt now
when even when you went through the car
when I won the seventh race I asked her
guess what I turned around to my mom he
said oh I think the teletext is broken
because Frankie is one I seven he
couldn't believe that he didn't believe
it but did he congratulate no he didn't
no no no are you serious of course
serious that's dad that's hilarious yeah
he's like yeah doesn't you if he says
nothing then he's well done yeah yeah
are you like that with your kids
completely the opposite spoil I give him
everything uh yeah complete the opposite
to my dad but you know but despite
despite the way he is your generation do
you think that that that work ethic that
will to win the competitive spirit all
of that do you think in the end you've
got a lot of your success because of the
way your dad was yeah absolutely that's
why I
I'm I'm I stop now asking him because I
always end up arguing with him it says
Dad you push me and you brainwash me to
become a champion you know what about
especially my sport if I I fre through
my career I would have broke my knee and
stopped riding I would have felt inside
would have felt a loser you know and he
turns on says well I can't answer that
look at you're a champion about what you
know he never gave a thought about
something Beyond you control that could
happen but you know but isn't that a
champion mentality yeah but it's it's
probably is but you know I got to some
way going to thank him to make me think
like that but it's something that I
can't do to my children maybe because
I'm new generation maybe because I'm
soft I just can't do it but you know
what was your mother what she been like
with you sorry has your mother been my
mom she's uh like mother you know loves
me my my my dad's super tough what was
your mother's proudest moment you think
maybe when you got the M MBE from the
queen um listen my mom she's you know
proud you know everything that do you
know she's typical mama she just want to
C me and feed me and you know
my my dad yeah I look my my dad is proud
too you obviously doesn't sure but but
you know like like what you said that
point if he wasn't for him pushing me I
would never be here because I didn't
have in me have you pointed out to him
that you've now continued for two years
longer than him uh no I don't want to
rub it in listen no the dad is 82 um
luckily still with me uh his brain is
good obviously he a bit fra but you know
I'm I I guess I'm keeping him Alive by
him watching me still ride so it's good
it's good that a lovely story Frankie
about you is that the seventh ride you
had at when you went through the car you
ended up keeping that horse as a pet so
basically fjam also won the seven he end
up going jump racing and U and I think
he had a pelvis injury so it was going
to end up God knows so I rang the
trainer and I said could I please buy of
him
and I took him home and became my pet
for 20 years he was he lived in the
field and he was the H one made me
famous he was the host who won the
seventh race and you know I gave him a
good life until the very end and he you
know he passed away one day in the field
it didn't suffer it just you know he
lived a rip old age till it was about 25
it's a lovely story well I owe it to him
you right he made me famous finally if I
could have the power to let you relive
any race in your entire career on any
horse again right now you can do it
right out on that track which one would
you
choose very hard to say um you only have
one I would say because it's fresh in my
mind this year's Champion Stakes my
everl last ride in England on my
retirement day the day that the queen
and V my statue
I win the Champions
Stakes I couldn't wrote it not I don't
think no even Hollywood could have wrote
the finale so I would say that to Pier
how would you like to be remembered if
you could write your own Tombstone here
lies Frankie Dori he I've had fun along
the way um uh and U yeah I was uh you
know i' I've I've did my job with a
smile in my face and we're both Arsenal
fans absolutely we're going through a
very tough tough period right now I know
we haven't I can't fix that we haven't
won the Premier League since 2004 I know
you're a miracle worker do you see any
Prospect we can do it this year yeah we
still got three weeks if we buy a nice
Center forward think weekend we got to
have a winner a striker come on a killer
come on got three weeks left come on we
got plenty of time to buy one Frankie
great to see you in Hollywood thank you
P all the
best
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costumes
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about talk today we do it all Dak sella
scans I rather like David Cameron I
don't sort of bear him any your will
because he delivered the referendum that
he said he would deliver the Israelis
are very conciliatory all they want is
to be recognized the timing of this
hamus attack comes because there was the
expectation that was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the tor's love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella braan she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what rashak has done the question now
is what he does next the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swear an o in the police to act without
fear or favor the co inquiry seems to
have turned into a sort of pantomim
there's not really any substance to it
it's hard to know whether it's a fce or
a tragedy talk TV has spoken exclusively
to a member of the Blade Runners do you
have a message for sadique Khan we're
not stopping until you stop
the amount of time it's taken the number
of illegal migrants currently sent by us
to Rwanda zil the amount of money it's
cost we're saying what are we saying
it's cost about 140 million 140 million
so far so40 million so far result nil
absolutely nil are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for AIT if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in for three years hundreds and hundreds
of mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man MC Mouse man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit presid Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film